The sauce, Kevin here. And I'm about to stretch my Winky on till it snaps.
Actually, I've got three of these anti-stress emoji people called
winkies only one will survive and you will witness an
incredibly simple problem that almost everyone gets wrong.
And at the end,
get to the bottom of one of the most famous probability problems ever.
It's time to meet the winkies orange purple and
blue. They've been sentenced to death,
but just one will be pardoned.
The other two are walking the green mile,
but they don't know which two it will be.
All they know is that I warden Kevin get to decide
right now each winkies chance of survival is one out of three.
So one over three plus one over three plus one over three equals one.
With every Winky, having an equal shot at living.
There's no paradox here yet.
The fairest least biased way to choose which Winky lives is to put three
slips of paper into a hat and randomly draw a color and a mix around your
slips. And here we go.
But what if they know that I drew a color
yet? I don't tell them which one it is.
These winkies would be left to wonder who will live,
who will die and what their own personal odds of survival
really are.
Kevin, Kevin, given,
you can tell me I can keep a secret. Tell me who will live.
I think he is talking to me and I think I recognize that voice
keeper of internet history. How'd you end up on death row.
Anyway. I can't tell you who survives. It's it's just not fair.
And I definitely can't tell you whether you live or die.
I understand you bear a heavy burden.
Just tell me one of the winkies that will be executed.
If purple lives. Tell me blue. If blue lips tell me,
and if I'm going to the live, just choose.
Which of the other two you'd like to name, do this for me, Kevin Queens.
Uh, I don't, I don't know orange Winkie. It really doesn't seem fair.
Air, please. Given pretty place USR handsome,
and those glasses look so good on you.
Oh, okay. What's the harm.
I can't possibly give orange Winky any useful information.
Blue will be executed right now
to, I didn't.
Mean to put his body back that way upside down, but you know what?
Warden Kevin is, uh, is a cruel warden.
Kevin, you fool. Now I never, my odds are 50 50.
I will live or purple will live.
There is no alternative use. Stupid stupid man.
Oh, he's so dumb and also fat. Oh no.
He's right. I got tricked by a Winkie.
Now there are only two choices. One will live and one will not.
So his odds improved from one out of three to 50
50, right? Wrong orange Winkie.
You still only have a one out of three chance to live.
And purple Winky is actually twice as likely to win the pardon.
This may remind you of the Monty hall problem and we'll get to why that's
important later.
But for now let's break down the only possible scenarios that orange Winkie
faced.
Remember that I can't tell orange Winkie whether he lives or
dies. When I named blue,
we can compare the two possible outcomes after naming blue
scenario one where I named blue and purple lives as a one out of
three probability of occurring scenario three,
where I named blue and orange libs has a one out of
six chance of happening since one over three is twice
as large as one over six.
And since they're the only two possible outcomes after naming
blue, meaning their probabilities have to add up to one.
Purple actually has a two out of three chance of survival.
And orange only has a one out of three chance of avoiding execution.
The probabilities of two events that appear to be equally
likely just aren't. And we can't handle that,
or it's time to reveal which Wiki will live and which Winkie will die.
This slip of paper determines our survivor and
purple lives. Sorry.
Kevin Gleason,
for you to know have calm history by buddy is strategic
[inaudible].
Yeah, cause I called that you fat.
I am dead.
Welcome to the three prisoners problem,
which is actually the Bertrand's box paradox and kind of the Monty
hall problem, but mostly the Bertrand's box paradox,
which came out the same year.
The Eiffel tower opened van Gogh painted the story night and Nintendo copay
first started producing playing cards.
They eventually made video games in 1889,
70 years before recreational math columnist,
Martin Gardner started playing mind games with prisoners on their execution
date, French mathematician,
Joseph Bertrand published how cool day probability in
which he posed a paradox that became the basis.
The Genesis for Monte hall and will require
me to stick my winkies.
In pudding. Let me explain. After.
Making me a plate of 10 DS and my favorite dipping sauce,
my mom's secretly hid winkies in these three large candy
dishes full of pudding.
One of them contains two winkies of the same color.
Another one contains two winkies of a different color.
And then one contains one Winkie. Each of those two colors.
I'm pretty sure that mom said one Winky color is yellow,
but I'm not sure what the other one is.
It's just so much grosser than I thought it was going to be.
Let's reveal this winkies color.
Thank you for looking me clean, Kevin, your tongue.
Is so smooth. How are you alive?
You can kill me. Kevin we're friends now. Okay,
well clearly we have an orange Winkie somehow back from the dead and we
know that the second Winky color is yellow,
but what are the chances that the other Winkie in this pudding is
also orange.
We know that the three dishes are orange, orange, orange, yellow,
and yellow, yellow.
Each combination is equally likely to be chosen at the star.
We also know that this can't be the yellow, yellow dish,
because I just pulled out the creepiest orange Winkie
on the planet. That means it's coming from orange, orange,
or from orange and yellow,
and both had the same chance of being selected.
Once we pull the orange Winky, we know that the odds,
the other Winkie in this dish is orange is 50 50,
because I've clearly chosen either the orange,
orange pudding or the orange yellow pudding, right.
Wrong again for the same mathematical reason as our prisoner
problem. This.
Is the mathematical foundation of all these
scenarios.
Our inability to recognize that what appears to be 50
50 really isn't hold on before I explain further,
let's just find out real quick where the winkies are,
because I actually don't know. Well, this was orange, orange.
It was orange, orange jar. Number two. I can't even tell that.
Okay, that's yellow. Now is this one orange? Or is this the yellow,
yellow jar time to find out it looks orange. It looks orange. Let's see. Yup.
There's the other orange. So that was our yellow orange,
which means that this has to be.
Yellow, yellow, yellow, yellow.
I have to clean up this pudding or else we can't continue the video.
So I'll be right back.
All right, now that the Vsauce muck bang portion of our video is complete.
Let's get to the root of this problem.
Bertrand conceived his original paradox with gold and silver coins
and boxes. He had the same basic setup. We used gold, gold, gold,
silver and silver, silver with the player, reaching into a random box,
drawing a gold coin and wondering about the odds of that box containing
another gold coin.
Once we pull on a gold coin or an orange Winky,
or one of the prisoners to be executed,
it feels like our odds of whatever comes next are an equal
50 50.
We're just choosing between two leftover options that appear to
be equally likely.
We know the other coin is either gold or silver, but look,
if you pull a gold coin, either poem gold coin,
one gold coin two or three.
And at this point you conceptually know that you're not dealing with the box
with the two silver coins. You don't know exactly what it is,
but you do know what it's not. If you choose gold one,
the other coin is gold two. If you choose gold two,
the other coin is gold one. If you choose gold three,
you'll get silver one. So two out of three times you draw gold.
It'll be paired with another gold. And only one time out of three,
will you get stuck with silver,
but it's almost impossible to shake the notion of two
equivalent options.
Even when the math shows us that it's wrong.
It's the same reason why the Monty hall problem is a problem.
The prisoner problem,
and Monty hall add a story to the math and an additional third party.
It seems like that would make it more complex,
but it actually helps you understand the probability more easily.
Adding a second player's perspective,
lets us see that the warding will never reveal who lives in Monty hall will
never reveal the door with the money.
Despite that additional information, we still get it wrong.
Why is it so hard when the solution is right in front of our
face? Probably because it is right in front of our face.
And it's why very,
very smart people often get it more wrong than right.
I mentioned this in my, what is a paradox video,
but when Marilyn Vos savant wrote in parade magazine,
that switching doors in the Monte hall problem resulted in a two over three
chance of success.
Instead of being an obvious 50 50 trade parade received over
10,000 letters telling her she was wrong,
about 1000 of them were signed by PhDs.
And she claims many were sent on official letterheads from college math
and science departments.
And I still get comments on my video from people all over the
world telling me that I'm wrong. Massimo,
Pia tele Paul Marini,
author of inevitable illusions said that no other statistical
puzzle comes close to fully all of the people all the time and
research in 1995 by Grantsburg and Brown found that only
13% of people correctly switched Monty
Hall's doors in a 2003 paper in the journal of experimental psychology,
Stefan Krauss and X T Wang described these particular problems from her trans
box to Monty hall as cognitive illusions,
stating that they demonstrate people's resistant deficiency in dealing with
uncertainty,
they found that only 3% in the control group solved the problem with
mathematically correct reasoning.
And that a significant problem was perspective when participants were
able to think of the problem from the perspective of Monte hall,
instead of the game show contestant or thinking as
me warden, Kevin, instead of as the prisoner orange Winkie,
their chances of choosing the right pathway improved,
vaulting them from simple non Basie,
thinking into more complex Bayesean analysis.
In the 1990s,
it appeared that there was no way to break the mathematical illusion of
Bertrand's box,
the three prisoners or the Monty hall problem explaining
the math just didn't seem to work.
It turns out the math isn't the problem. We are.
Uncertainty is hard for us.
Changing perspectives is harder,
your watching this video because you're a smart Jarius
person. And by altering your perspective,
you don't just dismiss a mathematical illusion that has
perplexed us for over a century because you have identified
it's flaw. You don't just solve it. You embrace it,
you absorb it, you understand it.
And you ultimately use it to your advantage.
You know it, and I know that I have.
So much pudding and as always,
thanks for watching.
I mean,
[inaudible].
You like thinking problems, solving logic and technology,
but what if you want to create technology? Where do you start? Well,
this video is sponsored by full sail university,
which offers bachelor's and master's degrees that focus on the evolving
needs of the technology industry.
Through hands-on accelerated degree programs,
you can familiarize yourself with the same tools and tech used by
industry professionals and with degrees like computer science,
information technology, mobile development, simulation, and web development.
There are a variety of degree programs offered to help you build
a very specific skillset. So to learn more about full sales programs,
as well as potential scholarship opportunities, visit full
sail.edu/b sauce too.
Bye.
Orange. You glad I didn't say banana. I'm picking up what you put in down.
Who put you up? Who put you up to this? Kevin? No, Kevin stop.
You're stretching me like Mrs. Incredible. On a first date.